Lényeg az, hogy hogy szoptatás alatt
megnő a szervezetnek az energiaigénye,
sokkal több cukorra van szüksége, mint
úy általában. És én elvállaltam egy
időben a az asszisztens asszisztenseknek
a belgyógyászati képzését, és ez azzal
járt, hogy elég, tehát este későn írtem
haza, és egész nap nem ettem semmit,
vagy bekaptam a a tepertőmet, ami ugye
szénhidrátot nem tartalmaz, csak
zsiradékot. Tehát, hogy ilyen egy ilyen
koplalás plusz ketózisban voltam, plusz
volt ez a tejtermelés, és ez a hármas
kombináció, ez nagyon rossz. És arra
lettem figyelmes, hogy ilyen őztartásban
merevedtek a kezeim, a lábaim. Nagyon
erős hasi görcsöm és hányingerem volt
egyébként a ketuaidózisnak ezek a
tipikus tünetei.
Hiperventiláltam, tehát hogy nagyon
gyorsan szuszogtam, gyorsan vert a
szívem, le voltam izzadva, nagyon
rosszul éreztem magam. Tehát konkrétan
azt éreztem, hogy én meg fogok halni.
เ